hi there Steve here again today I have
my beret that I picked up when my wife
and I were in pole in southern
southwestern France in 2007 and they had
the world rugby Cup was on and I got
this beret from the Basque Country it's
not gonna wear it today and I'm going to
talk about words the use of the
dictionary and and some rambling about
language I'm not entirely sure what I'm
gonna say what triggered this was on my
blog the linguist on language we have a
little bit of an exchange above the seal
hunt which is something that takes place
in Canada regularly it's been under a
lot of international media scrutiny the
Europeans have banned Canadian sealing
or sealed product so that the Norwegians
and the Russians can provide those
services and do exactly the same thing
as the Canadians do and I said that it's
hypocritical for someone who eats meat
too and and most of the meat we get he's
produced in circumstances that we
wouldn't want to see firsthand but
because people have gone and filmed the
seal hunt everybody's up in arms about
seal hunt but they don't film the
slaughterhouses and so forth so anyway
enough said
one of the people there said I can't use
the word hypocrisy because the
dictionary defines hypocrisy as this
whatever the definition was and I said
I'm not bound in my use of words by some
dictionary definition that someone might
find somewhere and this person came back
and said that he had never heard anyone
say anything quite as ridiculous as what
I had just said so to me the dictionary
comes after usage the dictionary doesn't
dictate usage the dictionary has to
constantly add definitions to reflect
how words are being used and there's
often more than one definition and when
I use a dictionary which and I nowadays
only use
online dictionaries I don't like
flipping through a dictionary and I
never have to me the meaning in the
dictionary is just kind of a beginning
just a hint and until I have seen that
word in many context I won't really know
what the word means or how it's used and
even after I've learned a few usages
I'll still be surprised to find yet
another usage of that word so that the
dictionary is just the beginning and so
I never for example some people love
dictionaries they value them they read
them they read all of the ten examples
that are given as that I never do that
I'm not interested in the examples that
are given in a dictionary I'm interested
in when I'm going to meet the word in
different context when I'm when I'm
reading so when I used to study
languages before the online dictionary
before link I would only read content
that had a glossary or a vocabulary list
behind each lesson because I hated
looking things up in the dictionary it
took forever and as soon as I closed the
dictionary I had already forgotten what
I had looked up so it was a tremendously
time-consuming and discouraging type of
thing to do and it also distracted me
from my reading the word this was
somewhat better because I could kind of
look at it ahead of time
in the hope that I would remember those
meanings when I read the lesson of
course most the time you don't because
you read the list you think you've
learned it and then you come across the
word and you've forgotten again so then
sometimes I would read and look at the
word list but that's very distracting
because you know you're disrupted and
often they give you a little indication
that this word is in the word list and
even though you know the word you look
it up and then you realize that in fact
you knew it but then the words that you
don't know aren't on the word list so
it's very unsatisfactory and that's
where we go in link let me say that I
consider the learning of words to be the
biggest task in
you go through that initial period where
you overcome the strangest of the
language you start to hear it you can
tell where words begin and end using you
if you want to you can even say if you
think you feel very proud of yourself
now you can say hello how are you my
name is so-and-so but then there is that
long process of acquiring enough words
so that you can follow a lot of
different discussions because after up
to me primarily language learning is
about understanding if I struggle saying
something it doesn't bother me you know
some people are concerned
I know people who speak English who make
lots of mistakes would have maybe
accents but when I speak to them they
understand everything I say those people
to my mind are fluent they're totally
with it they've come up with a manner of
speaking that's influenced by their
native language which is full of iock
sense or whatever it doesn't bother me
as long as they can understand and in
order to understand you need lots of
words and to me the learning of words is
like the milestones it's like I've often
mentioned you know I'm talking about
link where we track the number of words
that you've learned that you know any
phrase it's not totally scientific but
it helps this is like I call it the
mechanical rabbit at the dog races you
know they have dog races and have a
mechanical rabbit the dogs chase the
mechanical rabbit so the learning of
words a desire to increase your
vocabulary that's the driver you've got
to get more and more and more words how
do you get the words by doing a lot of
listening and reading and the occasional
review through flashcards through
reviewing lists looking at words seeing
like us you know all the things that we
do that I do it in my vocabulary section
at Linc I compare word see how they're
similar or in fact us again I appointed
other like when I read away from the
computer which is more pleasant I read
away from the computer if I have no more
than five see you know certainly under
10 percent preferably under five percent
new words so then I read a chapter and I
underline and I highlight all the words
and phrases in there that I want to
learn and then when I'm done I go to
Google Documents and I write out all
these
words and phrases and the great thing
about Google Documents is that they have
spell checkers there because inevitably
as you type in from a text from a list
you're gonna make spelling mistakes
furthermore I'm learning Portuguese even
if it's in Spanish
not to mention Russia I'm gonna make
spelling mistakes I'm you're missing
accents I'm gonna do all kinds of stuff
I don't want to switch keyboards all the
time I mean for example a French
keyboard is just hopeless because the
cue is where the a should be and the M
isn't there and a whole bunch of stuff I
like the type in English even my Russian
I use a virtual keyboard I type in
English fill it with the odd missing
letter in the case of Russian by having
there the keyboard up on my screen but
if I do it in a spellchecker environment
like the Google Documents then I just
check for spelling make sure everything
is correct but in the accents the
cedilha is whatever it might be I then
take that paragraph which might be 100
150 words if you're not on a link then
you just go to an online dictionary or
if you coming - link I import them and
then I go through any words that I have
already been trying to learn in link
will be highlighted in yellow because
many words that you think you don't know
you've already been trying to learn them
and then I go through and I save them to
link I get the meaning and then I get my
flashcards and so forth and so on but in
all of this the dictionary is not some
great Bible the dictionary whether it be
online or whether it be a book but I
prefer online because it's fast like
Google Translate is an excellent
dictionary it covers a lot of the words
it covers phrases I have it available
for words and phrases doesn't do as good
a job on longer paragraphs it gives you
a hint it might be a little funny
sometimes but it kind of gives you a
hint I don't worry about it I just put
that in that's the hint link I'll see it
again I might refine the hint the main
thing is I know I've got to see the word
again
so what I'm driving in all of this is
language learning is about increasing
words you know that is passively that
you understand eventually if you know
enough words possibly you'll start to
use them be if you speak poorly but you
understand everything that's not a
problem in mind if it you debbie's you
can get your meanie across see the
dictionary does not define the meaning
of words it gives us hints and the
dictionary is just a tool amongst many
but you are not going to learn words
from the dictionary in my opinion you're
going to learn them from meeting them in
different contexts yeah basically that's
what I had to say words that's what it's
all about get many words don't be don't
treat the lectionary as a Bible use it
as infrequently as possible because it's
hard to spend so much time looking
flipping through a dictionary when you
know you're gonna forget to work
that's where online dictionaries come in
and the advantage of doing your
dictionary searching online is that you
can then create lists whether you're
linked or whether you're in and key or
some other program so again staying
within my ten minutes that's what I had
to say and look forward to hearing your
comments bye for now